without even hitting a ball in
competition novak djokovic was on his
way home
no doubt contemplating the madness of
the past 10 days
for the unvaccinated defending champion
the australian open was closed
his visa was cancelled twice by the
australian government and his serbian
fans were out in force at belgrade
airport for their national hero
i think that he doesn't influence
whether people get vaccinated or not
in fact he helped a lot of countries in
these difficult times with various
donations for people to get vaccinated
and so on
he has his reason why he doesn't want to
be vaccinated he doesn't want to say
what that reason is but it is his human
right not to get vaccinated djokovic
thought he had a medical exemption
before traveling down under but being
booted out of australia has fired up the
debate about how unvaccinated athletes
travel the world the government in
france have said that everyone at the
french open in may will need a vaccine
pass to get in
he has no vocation to play if he's not
vaccinated if he's not going to respect
a rule that applies to spectators the
ball boys or the professionals with
shops at roland garros what world would
it be if we considered that just because
you're a star you can question the rules
i say no
djokovic needs to be playing grand slams
his sponsors need him out on court too
clothing firm lacoste is one of them and
they've said they want to review into
what happened in australia make no
mistake novak djokovic is the number one
tennis player in the world so he's got
sponsorship options you know if one
sponsor pulls out there will be another
who will take a different view and and
go with him so i don't think the
sponsors will have particularly huge
leverage in terms of making him do what
they want djokovic says now he wants to
let the australian open take center
stage
but he will be back
somehow
tom parmenter sky news